MALE SPEAKER: Hi, everybody.
Welcome.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MALE SPEAKER: No, it is not.
Apparently we're starting
to do a little comedy.
Welcome to Authors at Google
presents "Ultrasylvania." The
writer and the art director
of "Ultrasylvania" will be
speaking today about the project
itself, which was done
in collaboration with the
Academy of Art University in
San Francisco and also a
Kickstarter project.
So we have two people today, the
writer Brian Schirmer and
the co-creator and art director
Jeremy Saliba.
Brian Schirmer has written
comics and screenplays for
most of his adult life,
following aborted attempts as
a teenager to write "Indiana
Jones" and "Star Trek" novels.
His first attempt at
screenwriting was a
handwritten adaption of Marvel's
first "Micronauts"
comic series, circa 1980.
It's in a box somewhere.
He is the author of the comic
anthology "Worlds Apart" and
the original graphic novel
"White Tower" due from
Committed Comics in 2013.
He has written, produced, and
directed two feature films--
"Fools of the Game" and "Medium
Gray"-- the latter of
which screened in Park
City during the 2004
Sundance Film Festival.
Nevertheless, pretty cool.
He continues to write and teach
Writing for Comics in
San Francisco, California.
Jeremy Saliba is a lover of all
things nerdy and has used
that passion to continue
creating artwork despite the
pleading from family and
friends to stop.
He has done artwork for various
comic publications and
has become a licensed "Wheel of
Time" artist and sells art
prints online.
He also inflicts his twisted
and self-absorbed point of
view on his students at
the Academy of Art.
He's a movie fanatic, a
bookworm, and a beer
enthusiast.
His imaginary friend when he was
little was Princess Leia,
and he will never say no if you
ask him to help you move.
He also hates talking
in the third person.
Ladies and Gentlemen, please
welcome Brian Schirmer and
Jeremy Saliba.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Thank
you, Chris.
Thank you, Googlers,
here and abroad.
I'm Brian.
This is Jeremy.
JEREMY SALIBA: Hey.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: And
we are behind
"Ultrasylvania," as he said.
We titled this presentation the
Road to "Ultrasylvania"
because we wanted to basically
show you the path that we took
from initial conception all
the way to even here today
because it's an ongoing
project.
We, he and I, have been working
together in comics for
about five years now.
As Chris mentioned, we
collaborated on an anthology
called "Worlds Apart," which
I'm happy to say-- and that
doesn't come out quite right--
but happy to say is actually
out of print now because
we sold all of them.
So that's fantastic.
JEREMY SALIBA: Right.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: And yeah.
I write, and Jeremy's been
an Illustrator for ages.
JEREMY SALIBA: Yeah, yeah.
Yeah That was kind of our first
foray for us into this
collaborative kind of thing,
and we both just wanted to
work on a project together.
Well, he had an idea to do
several short stories that
involve various artists.
And he and I clicked really well
right away and all that
kind of stuff and have done
a couple short stories and
pitches since then.
But both of our schedules were
precluding something really,
really hugely committed in terms
of like a graphic novel
or anything.
And then Brian, took a little
trip and got some funny ideas.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Yeah.
Summer of 2011, I went to Europe
because I hadn't been
in about 20 years, and
I figured I can go
into debt for this.
So I did, and did some
traveling, blah, blah, biblah,
and saw some amazing sites and
some fantastic cities.
And basically came up--
I was keeping a notebook of just
any ideas that would come
across like, to my opinion,
any good writer should.
And a couple of ones that came
up and stuck had to do with
the notion of what if
Frankenstein's monster and
Dracula were world leaders,
instead of these creatures in
the darkness and ill-fated
and what have you.
As I say, these were just a
couple of ideas amongst a
myriad of others that I jotted
down, but they kind
of stuck with me.
As was mentioned, I think, we
both teach and have taught at
the Academy of Art here
in San Francisco.
And basically what happened
was, I was approached by a
former student who said, why
don't they have a class here
that we could take one of your
comic scripts and make it a
class where students would come
in and do the artwork,
basically a collaborative.
And I laughed at him immediately
and probably made
him feel very small.
As fate would have it, about
three or four days went by,
and I still couldn't
shake this notion.
And I mentioned it to Jeremy,
and we talked
about it very briefly.
And then we decided, you know,
let's go talk to the head of
the School of Illustration,
Chuck Pyle,
and see what he thinks.
And yeah, he had some very
pointed questions about our
plans and what we thought
we would accomplish.
And we said, well,
we'll do this.
We'll come up with this great
story, and we'll give it to
the students and they'll work
on it and we'll put it out.
It'll be a web comic, and then
we'll run a Kickstarter to
fund the printing of it.
And then we'll have it at
conventions and premiere and
give it to industry people, and
then get it on Amazon and
get it in stores.
And he said, OK, that
sounds good.
Let's do that.
And in the back of my mind I'm
thinking, OK, if we hit one or
two of those goals,
we're doing OK.
I forgot to put this in here.
This is the original
solicitation poster for the
class that Jeremy
put together.
I guess this is probably
the original--
the first initial artwork that
we had of any kind, based on
the script and the notes that
existed at the time.
So we had a very solid response
from students.
I should point out that it was
not an open class, as it were.
It wasn't something that anybody
could sign up for.
We were basically given carte
blanche to handpick who we
wanted in the class.
So students either had to submit
a portfolio, in some
cases, a couple of them were
students we already knew, so
we knew their work.
We knew the quality that they
would bring and the
commitment.
JEREMY SALIBA: In this case,
having a working knowledge of
how things are at the Academy
and what facilities were
available to us was a
big leg up because--
this, what Brian's showing you
a picture of here is the
Centique lab at the Academy.
And for anyone who may not be
familiar with Centique, it's a
drawing tablet that
is a monitor.
So you just use a stylus and
draw it on it and create
digital artwork that way,
primarily using Photoshop but
really, any drawing
program will do.
And I've taught in that
classroom for quite a while.
I'm very familiar with the
technology, and students are
very excited about
the technology.
So we had that going for us.
And we asked Chuck, can
we teach in there?
As it happens, I have a lot of
experience working on those
and teaching in there, so he
said, sure, that sounds great.
And it helps with the
students, too.
They get excited to have access
to this kind of really
high-end industry professional
materials.
So that, and also having worked
at the Academy for a
while, we had a pretty good
knowledge of the students.
I'd had quite a few students
come through my classes.
We always make note of the good
ones, the competition, as
I call them.
And when this idea started
crystallizing, I had a short
list already going in my head of
people I would ask to join
us in the classroom.
So that working knowledge of
everything there, I think,
helped speed up the process
more than we
thought it would go.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Yes.
To date, we've run this class
twice, and each time has
resulted in a volume of the
story, which-- and I don't
think I've even given
the basic spiel--
which, beyond the original note
that I jotted down that I
mentioned about Frankenstein and
Dracula as world leaders,
it evolved into this story that
basically stretches--
First of all, it stretches
throughout the entire 19th
century and basically recarves
the European and worldwide
landscape based on something
that Napoleon's forces unearth
when they were in Egypt
in 1799, I believe.
But it's more than that.
That's really just a setting.
It's a place for us to go play
with these characters and have
them have real lives and deal
with, as they say, political
intrigues and assassination
attempts.
JEREMY SALIBA: Well, even given
that core story, it
involves a lot of fun sub-genres
in comics.
Alternate history is a big
fun thing to play with.
When you have an alternate
history, you get to kind of
then mess around with the
evolution of technology a
little bit, which inevitably
will at least touch upon
steampunk kind of things,
which is a
very popular sub-genre.
And we also have the monster,
the classic monster movie
genre, that we're playing with
in there with Frankenstein and
Dracula and the Mummy.
So all of those things
were at our disposal.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: And tweaking
expectations, I think.
I don't think either one of us
are really huge fans of,
perhaps, movie
re-interpretations of things
that have come down the
pipe in recent years.
Although some might deduce that
that's what we're doing,
it was really more taking--
not taking liberties.
For example, rather than
having Dracula have a
Renfield, we give him a guy
named Redford, who's an
American and basically winds up
becoming known as Renfield.
And I'll give a little something
away here-- that
Bram Stoker himself is an actual
character in the first
volume of this story coming to
ostensibly write a biography
of Dracula and ultimately
winds up writing the
book that we know.
JEREMY SALIBA: Right, right.
So with all these ideas at our
back, Brian wrote the script,
and we brought it
to the students.
And they were really excited.
They seemed to be overjoyed at
the idea of yeah, let's make a
comic with a script in place
written by a professional.
We have another professional
who's going to oversee and
guide everything for us.
So it was really enthusiastic
and a lot of fun.
I tend to kind of try to have
fun when I'm teaching anyways
because that can be
a pretty bland
experience in some cases.
But if we're doing comics,
it should be fun.
So it was an interesting
in-class experience.
I was the official teacher,
although Brian was pretty much
there for every minute of
the class to weigh in.
You know, when looking at
artistic interpretations of
the ideas in his script,
sometimes, a lot of times, a
student will have a completely
different idea than what I was
thinking of.
And sometimes, that's a great
thing, and sometimes it's a
little off the rails and
not what we wanted.
And other times, I find it to
be a little bit of a draw.
Those are the times when I find
Brian being there to be
the most valuable.
He's my great tiebreaker.
And it's like, your idea's
great, and my idea's clearly
awesome, but which one
should we go with?
And Brian's pretty impartial.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: I sit in a
throne at the very front of
the classroom where we have a
screen, and I will either--
I'm the Roman praetor.
JEREMY SALIBA: We need
to get you a scepter.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: That
would be lovely.
Basically, the first volume came
to fruition, and within
less than a week, we launched
the web comic, which is
ultrasylvania.com.
And that started in May of 2012,
and we've been running
three pages a week
ever since then.
And I'm very proud to say we've
never missed a day.
JEREMY SALIBA: That's right.
I was going to talk a little
more about the classroom
experience, too.
I was running--
primarily, it was a
critique session.
One of the first things I had
mentioned to the students is,
we're not going to run this
like a traditional class.
Normally, in an art class like
this with students, you put
the burden of finding reference
on them because
that's part of the creative
process that they must learn.
Whereas in this case, we want
to make as good a book as
possible, so Brian did
a lot of research.
I did some research.
And we brought it to the class
and provided it for them.
So already, again, they
were very excited.
And it's like, we get all this
already just handed to us?
And this is more of a
professional environment.
If we have something specific
we want you to utilize to
create this, we should provide
that for you, at least steer
you in that direction.
And so most of that semester was
them bringing in the work
and us dissecting it, going
over it, looking at it.
And as much as we kept
it professional--
obviously they're still in
school, so they don't know
everything.
So that's kind of where the
teaching element, for me at
least, would come in, discussing
some of the basics,
like crossing the line or
general rules of layout or the
flow of the eye through
a page.
Digging into that kind of stuff
and making sure that
they understand these
fundamentals, as well as
pushing them to be as
professional as possible.
One of the other things that's
kind of fun about the class,
for me in having Brian there, is
that he and I are a little
bit of a yin and a yang.
When it comes to subverting
expectations and tweaking
things in a way that people
might not expect, Brian's a
big fan of that.
I am, too, but Brian likes to
go a more subtle route.
With monsters it's, well, it's
a monster, but we're going to
keep them a little bit more
distinguished, a little bit
more not so classic, universal,
black and white,
Hollywood version.
And I'm the pulpy guy.
I'm the guy who's like, yeah,
let's have them rip up the
ground and throw rocks
at people if he's
Frankenstein, right?
Like the Hulk, right?
And so Brian will typically rein
me in, and I'll kind of
amp him up with kind of a fun
back and forth, trying to meet
things in the middle.
Not completely going overboard,
but at the same
time, not trying to
stay too somber.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: And frequently
the students themselves are
the random element.
More often than not, he'll
have some idea, and I'll
temper it down or vice versa.
And then the student will
come in and say, well,
why don't I do this?
And they'll show us the artwork
and we'll go, that's
so much better than what
I wrote in the script.
Thank you, thank you.
This is fantastic.
A for the day.
JEREMY SALIBA: Having that
trust-- like if you're going
to collaborate with a group of
people, if you want them to be
really involved, you want them
to have an input, right?
You want them to put their own
stamp on things and to have a
value in it because they're a
part owner of the ideas, of
the process of creating it,
and that can create
enthusiasm as well.
But also, I mean, we're
extremely fallible, so anyone
who has any ideas, please
bring them before us.
You'd rather hear a bad idea and
discard it than have you
not bring up a good idea that
would've really come in handy.
And to me, that's been one of
the most rewarding parts of
this process is having this
really truly open,
collaborative vibe throughout
the whole thing, where
anyone's free at any point to
come up and have a suggestion,
have an idea.
And we make that clear
right away, too.
If anyone has any ideas,
we'd love to hear them.
Sometimes students come in with
crazy ideas, and I get a
little torn because that
sounds amazing.
Yes, Frankenstein should fight
a bear out in the woods.
That's a great idea, but it just
doesn't fit in this part
of the book at all, so we're
going to have to not use that.
But maybe a short story
somewhere else, where he
fights a giant octopus
in the ocean.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: But
I do always--
in almost every script that I've
ever written for him or
for the students or anyone--
I always preface it with,
this is a blueprint.
If you have a better idea for
something, I trust you.
You are coming to this
as the visual artist.
I have a bit of a visual art
background, but you are making
this your career.
You are making a career choice
to do this stuff.
And either go for it, or if
you're kind of not sure if you
think it's right, let's
talk about it.
Because I don't want to,
basically, be coming in there
and saying, no, this
is what I wrote.
This is what the
comic will be.
I don't want to be
that person.
JEREMY SALIBA: Yeah,
that's not fun.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: No.
Please.
AUDIENCE: Just about how much
of the whole script do you
guys have fleshed out or just
your whole timeline?
BRIAN SCHIRMER: How much of the
whole script do we have
fleshed out ahead of time?
AUDIENCE: Well, I'm just kind
of curious more about-- you
seem to have these
deadlines, like
Monday, Wednesday, Friday.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Sure.
JEREMY SALIBA: Right, right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JEREMY SALIBA: Well, he has
the script done before the
class starts.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
JEREMY SALIBA: Yeah.
Yeah, we have, obviously,
like you noted,
we have these deadlines.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Part of the
beauty is that, basically,
when a semester ends, which is
when the class ends, which is
when a volume ends, and then we
go into that volume on the
website, everything's done.
So that is what has really
enabled us to hit the Monday,
Wednesday, Friday deadline.
If I'm really fortunate and all
the artwork is done and
I've done all the lettering,
theoretically, I can put all
that into the website, and I
just sit back and wait for it
to roll out every couple days,
thanks to the backbone.
JEREMY SALIBA: Right.
And part of this web comic
experience was another big
selling point for the Academy,
as well as the students.
And one of our big declarations
at the beginning
was that our goal
was promotion.
Our goal was to get everyone's
name out there who was
involved in the book.
Students want that terribly.
They want to make a name for
themselves in the business.
And comics, while it can be a
lucrative business, can also
just be a passion business that
you do where you're not
necessarily making
a lot of money.
And I think you can't go into
it looking to make money or
your soul will be crushed far
too early and far too quickly.
Because you have to go in to
want to tell the stories that
you want to tell or make cool
art or whatever your
passion on it is.
So that was always
the first step.
And I don't know, Brian
handles the web
comic side of things.
But to me, it seems like one
of the easier steps of this
whole process in terms of the
outlook we had for the future
of this book, with having it
sell on certain websites,
having a Kickstarter, all
that kind of stuff.
So that was the one kind of
surefire thing we knew and
that we could guarantee the
students, well, it's going to
be a web comic, and it'll launch
right after class.
So it's been an integral part
of everything for us and has
gotten some fun readership.
And we get some fun feedback,
and people are leaving
comments and looking for the
next step and sharing their
shock when something
exciting happens.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Yeah.
As I said before, we knew we
could do the web comic.
That was easy, all things
considered.
But then our next goal was OK,
well, web comics are great.
But I think we're still fans of
printed media, and we knew
we wanted to do that.
We knew it wasn't necessarily a
cheap thing, but we also, of
course, knew about
Kickstarter.
And so, probably, three months
or so after the web comic
launched, we went ahead and did
a campaign on Kickstarter
looking to raise just enough,
basically, enough money to do
an offset printing of
the first volume.
And for those who don't know
about Kickstarter, it's
basically a platform where you
can go and raise money for an
artistic endeavor, in
our case, comics.
But they also do film and
theater and books of any kind.
JEREMY SALIBA: Products,
in some cases.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Electronics.
JEREMY SALIBA: Right.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: And yeah, so
we basically set a goal.
In our case, we were going out
for $8,500, which was going to
fund the printing and the
supplemental little rewards
that would be given to people
that would be supporters.
And with Kickstarter,
if you don't
know, it's all or nothing.
So we were setting
a goal of $8,500.
If we made it, great.
There's going to be a book.
If we didn't, we got nothing,
and we would be very happy to
continue with the web comic.
We were very pleased and
surprised that it got traction
almost immediately, and we
certainly made our goal.
We exceeded our goal.
We got about 130%
of what we were
after, which was fantastic.
And we got some lovely press
along the way and support from
industry professionals by way of
everything from people who
actually backed the book to
folks who gave us shout outs
on Twitter or on
their website.
JEREMY SALIBA: It
went very well.
I think in the interest of
really discussing the process,
Brian did a lot of leg work
ahead of time, too.
He really set up connections
with people, did all his
networking, conventions, other
things of that nature.
And was sending out PDFs, copies
of the book ahead of
the Kickstarter campaign saying,
hey, this is our book.
This is this new thing we came
up with at this class where
we're teaching students to make
a book and getting it out
there, and what do you think?
I think laying some initial
groundwork before starting
something like a Kickstarter
is a big part of-- it can
really help your odds of success
because then people
are looking for it.
They're ready for it.
In this case, we knew a
gentleman who was working for
the store Things From Another
World, and he was a big
supporter of it.
And brought up the idea that,
oh, maybe we should work
together and maybe we could sell
your book at our store.
We were like, oh, that
sounds terrible.
Yes, we'll do it.
So things like that, where he
did a lot of leg work ahead of
time, were fantastic.
I think the other aspect that
helped the Kickstarter become
successful was, again, having
this little mini-phalanx of
students in our class.
Online presences can
be quite vast.
It seems like the younger a
person is, the more-- you know
the digital natives who grew
up with this stuff just fly
through the internet
faster than my
old-man eyes can handle.
So then they were getting
the word out.
And then they'd tell
two friends, and
they'd tell two friends.
So having that core group of
people together, I think,
really helped the visibility.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: One of the
things, though, that really
surprised me and still does to
this day was, as you can see,
we got 367 backers.
I would say only about
a third of those were
people that we knew.
We meaning Jeremy and I, meaning
the students, meaning
their families.
So about 200 of those people,
we have no idea.
People from around the world
were backing this thing.
People in our backyard that--
I don't know who
this person is.
They live three blocks
from me, but they're
backing this book.
And that was just phenomenal
that it had that kind of
reach, and people seemed to
want to be a part of it.
And it was really rather amazing
when we were done, and
I'm looking at the breakdowns
of where everyone's from.
And we've got Brazil, Belgium,
Australia, England of course,
France, most of Europe.
Yeah, and it was just--
I'm still flabbergasted.
JEREMY SALIBA: I think the other
thing that's important
to discuss about people who
are just new to doing
Kickstarter campaigns is I've
had such a positive
experience with it.
We did one.
It got more than we asked for.
It was awesome.
It was wonderful.
And so I just kind of for a
while there was seeing it as
this magic well of money.
Yay, if you want something,
go to Kickstarter.
But I've since talked to other
people who've done it and
people who have run
Kickstarters
that did not succeed.
And I helped run the Kickstarter
campaign, but
Brian spearheaded it, and
it's a full-time job.
That's the one thing.
It's a great place to go if
you want to get, whatever,
your work out there, get
something published, whatever
it is your artistic endeavor is
that requires some money.
It's amazing, but you've got
to be ready because it's at
least, what, eight
hours a day.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: You get out
what you put into it.
I have known people that have,
again, done eight or more
hours a day working on their
Kickstarter, and it shows and
they get results.
And I've known other people that
basically turn it on and
walk away, and are then
flummoxed two, three weeks
later when they only
have four backers.
You have to be realistic
about it.
And if you already have
a full-time job,
it's a second one.
Congratulations.
But the rewards are
self-evident.
Again, we did this and
wound up with this.
We wound up with a printed book
that we were then able
to, of course, send to all the
people that supported us,
along with the other goodies,
but then also sell.
And our first sales experience
was really going around to
conventions and showing
it to folks.
Or actually, I take that back.
No, our first experience
was this is--
so this is a good , if not all,
then most of the students
who actually worked
on Volume One.
And after the books came in,
we naturally needed to send
them out to the 367 people
who supported us.
So we basically had a day where
we acquired one of the
rooms at the Academy
and took it over.
And what you're seeing here is
them putting sketches in
virtually all of the books
that went out.
And then we signed everything,
packaged everything.
Basically, it does
not end when the
Kickstarter campaign ends.
You don't just suddenly get, oh
hurray, all this money is
now in my account.
Boom, we're done.
No, that's when--
I don't want to say when the
real work begins-- but that's
when the next stage of
the real work begins.
But then, yes, we were able to
move on to conventions and
selling stuff.
I went to New York.
Oh, that was the other thing.
Again, part of our original
plan was having a debut at
conventions.
And we were fortunate enough
to have the only bi-coastal
debut taking place at New York
Comic Con and APE, the
Alternative Press Expo here in
San Francisco, which just
happened to be the same
weekend last year.
I went to New York.
Jeremy was here with some of
the guys from the book.
And we got some press for
that, which was great.
And definitely had some people
come up to us at the
conventions saying, oh, I backed
this, or I saw this on
Bleeding Cool or io9 or any of
the other sites that actually
covered us.
For me, that's still one of
the more amazing things is
like, people coming up to
me and saying oh yeah, I
recognize you from blah.
And it's like really?
I live in a small apartment
in San Francisco.
Thank you, thank you.
And we managed to meet some
luminaries along the way that
gave us some support.
That's Dave Gibbons, who was the
illustrator on "Watchmen"
most notably, but still a big
wheel in comics today.
That's me hanging with Grant
Morrison, who was a kind
enough gentleman--
JEREMY SALIBA: [INAUDIBLE]
you guys, right?
[INAUDIBLE].
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Oh
yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're like this.
And we have since also done
book signings, in-store
signings here in the Bay
Area, of which I should
definitely say that--
if this is something that anyone
wants to do, insofar as
getting a book published and
getting it out there, going
door-to-door to--
if you are fortunate to live
in an area that has comic
shops, go to them.
Tell them that you're
doing this thing.
More often than not, they are
going to be very excited and
supportive of the notion of
local artists because their
customers tend to be interested
in that as well.
We've probably done, what, four
or five signings here in
the Bay Area since last fall?
And it's a wonderful time.
And it's great meeting the
owners of the businesses and
seeing what their
lives are like.
And again, more often than not,
they are very, very much
in our corner.
JEREMY SALIBA: This guy's
telling me he doesn't like the
book, and I'm like, what?
You're dumb.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Oh, we're
getting ahead of ourselves a
little bit.
JEREMY SALIBA: The comic shop
experience has been
a really fun one.
And it gives it, I don't know,
like this whole grassroots
element of it is a very
appealing part of the process.
I mean, it's amazing what you
can do by sending off an email
or picking up the phone.
And I imagine this applies to
things outside of comics
greatly as well.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: I also want to
jump in and say, again, with
regard to the local
comic shops, we've
never been turned way.
Anybody that I've gone
to and said, oh hey,
we've got this book.
They've said, great, we
want to carry it.
Do you have any with
you right now?
And more than half of them
have said, oh, wonderful.
Do you guys want to come
in and do a signing?
Sure, all right.
Let's to do that.
And we've been very fortunate
with, as I say, with everyone.
JEREMY SALIBA: Yeah, yeah.
The industry is very supportive,
which is nice.
I think local comic shops,
there's some competition with
the little comic shop with
digital comics and stuff now.
So that's another thing that's
an incentive for them to say,
yeah, let's generate
some interest.
With the last one we did in
Concord, we were there for
their first one, if I understand
correctly.
They're going to do these Friday
night pizza nights at
their comic shop, where they
have pizza and have artists or
anyone involved in the industry
come by and show
their wares, talk about their
experiences, whatever.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: In a very
casual, relaxed atmosphere of
a comic shop.
They're not up there at a podium
or a big table saying,
hello, I make comics
and ba ba ba.
It's very much, hey, let's
grab a slice of
pizza and chat geekery.
But one other element
that I was almost
skipping over entirely--
it was, again, we went from web
comic to we got the book
published or printed, and
we were selling it.
We were doing signings in
stores and selling at
conventions.
Our next hurdle was getting
it out to broader
retailers, ie, Amazon.
And again, as Jerry mentioned,
Things From Another World,
which is also known as TFAW, is
sort of a comics and toys
and whatnot retailer up and down
the West Coast of the US.
But they also a web presence.
And we were fortunate to get
both books approved to be
carried online, which I think
was just, again, another step
in the legitimacy, I guess,
of the project.
That most people will now see
it as, oh, well, they're not
just selling it for $10
and a handshake at
a convention table.
I can be sitting on my computer
anywhere in the world
and look it up and, lo and
behold, there's the book.
I can sell, I can buy.
JEREMY SALIBA: It's
a nice thing.
Your friends say, oh,
a friend of mine was
asking about your book.
Where is it?
Where can they get it online?
Just one word, Amazon.
And you say, you can get it
there and everyone knows
exactly how to get there.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When you guys gave it
to the local retailers do
they buy it off you and then
sell it for more [INAUDIBLE]?
JEREMY SALIBA: When we give it
to local retailers, do they
buy it off us and then
sell it for more or--
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Yes.
Local retailers--
our experience has been, the
base standard, is they pay a
wholesale of 50%.
A little marketing ploy that I
picked up from someone else is
when they say, we'd like
to buy some copies.
We pay 50% of your retail.
And I then turn around and
say, you know what?
Yes, but we're going
to sell them to you
for 40% of the retail.
So you're getting it even
cheaper than you're getting it
from other people, with the
nod and the incentive that
they are more encouraged to
sell and to promote these
books because they will then
themselves be making more
money on the back
end of the sale.
And no one has turned
that down.
JEREMY SALIBA: Yeah.
No, no, we insist, 50%.
[? I wonder if that's ?]
happened yet.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Not yet.
JEREMY SALIBA: But yeah,
I mean, it's been an
overwhelmingly positive
experience.
It's a surprisingly large
amount of work.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: It is
not for the weak.
JEREMY SALIBA: Going back to the
students and everything, I
mean, they've all been extremely
enthusiastic and
supportive, but there's
some wrangling to do.
As with any collaborative
project, someone's not holding
up their end of the bargain.
Someone's not quite on
time with something.
And you've got to kind of--
that was one of my heavy tasks,
anyways, was to get
after those guys, getting
them available for
signings and for things.
Again, most of them were really
excited about it.
Even some of the Kickstarter
rewards that we did involved
like the artist, like,
sketching.
Or, there was one Kickstarter
reward that we set up where
it's like a night out the
creators, where we said,
someone who backs us for
such amount of money,
we'll take you out.
We'll take you out for comics
and go out to dinner and have
drinks or whatever.
And a few people bought that.
One of the artists that was
really just a standout
supporter and star of the book,
we took him out, too, to
celebrate and everything.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: I'm sorry.
Right, because the only
obligation that the artists
have, because they're students,
is to actually
attend the class and
turn in work.
In truth, the semester's
only 15 weeks long.
Once it's over, their official
obligation to it is done.
We are hopeful, from day one,
that they are going to be
proud of the work that they do
and that they want it to
succeed and go farther and be
able to do these, be able to
do signings and get the books
into the hands of the public
and into the hands of industry
people and basically have this
calling card.
Most of them are gung ho
and do want to do that.
But occasionally, you
get someone who's
like, OK, I did this.
I did this, I did
some good work.
I got my grade or I graduated,
and it's, like, so long and
good luck, which, that's fine.
I'm happy that that's the
exception rather than the
rule, of course.
JEREMY SALIBA: There's been a
couple of students who we
haven't heard from since
the class ended,
but that's all right.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: These
things happen.
So after about a year-- it
was about a year from the
conception of the class and
getting it approved to having
the book come out on Amazon.
And as I mentioned earlier,
we had that first meeting.
And we were saying, yeah, we're
going to have a website
and we're going to do a
Kickstarter and it's going to
go into print.
And then we're going to have it
in stores, and then we're
going to have it on Amazon.
And it was around the time that
we actually got it on
Amazon that I realized we
did all of those things.
I guess I would have been so
impressed if we had just had a
web comic and been able
to just point to that.
But the fact that we soldiered
on, and people were interested
and it's thrived--
it's wonderful.
JEREMY SALIBA: Yeah.
I attribute a lot of
that push to Brian.
As happy as he is to get to
where he got and as happy as
he would have been to just
have the bare minimum.
We work together, and we
had many conversations.
We said, we got to go.
We got to do this.
We got to push a little
harder, get it
out a little further.
And I think that mentality is
a lot of what makes it go
further, what makes it more
successful, what makes it
complete is that drive.
It related to, obviously,
talking about the commitment
to your Kickstarter campaign, if
you do something like that.
He had no other obligation to
sit in on the classes other
than he wanted to be there
for that input.
But he was always there and
providing input and
everything.
He's just been a very strong
presence for all that.
And there's a lot of discussion
about the paradigm
shift these days with--
I think Patton Oswald had
a great manifesto on it.
But in any industry, you don't
have to go to a big company
anymore to get your
work out there.
No matter what area you're in,
you can get it out there.
And I think it takes talent.
It takes skill and the drive.
It's cliche and it's a trite
thing to say, but it's
absolutely effective.
And just getting up and saying,
let's go a little
further, let's push a little
harder every day-- which is
definitely Brian's tactic
on all this--
is what will push it through.
Emailing people that you never
thought would back you or who
would spread the word to their
friends or buy a comic.
Emailing the stores, emailing
the online distributors,
talking to them, telling
them about your book.
Just having no fear.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: And firing those
arrows into the air and
just crossing your fingers.
I teach a Writing for Comics
class at the Academy, and I'm
always stunned by the number
of students who have no
interest in Twitter
whatsoever.
And they don't know
what it's for.
They don't know what they
would use it for.
And I said, dude, if I didn't
have Twitter, and if I didn't
use Twitter towards my
goals, we would've
accomplished nothing.
For me, it was really a tool for
finding industry people,
befriending them either
in person at first
or maybe via Twitter.
There are people that I've
certainly met on Twitter that
I've now met in real life that
I now consider friends.
But also we got some big pushes
from people like Warren
Ellis and Kurt Busiek and others
who we, basically, we
would tell them about the web
comic, or we told them about
the Kickstarter.
And they went, that's pretty
cool, and then they would
spread the word.
And yeah, that's invaluable
in this day and age.
JEREMY SALIBA: That was
another thing that was
surprising to me is how much the
industry people themselves
totally embraced it.
And I would imagine that's true,
again, for almost any
industry that you're
looking at.
If someone sees you and sees
you're trying to do good work
and trying to get it out
there, it's amazing how
supportive those industries
can be.
And so, if you're ever trying
to do anything on your own,
anything in your own avenue,
look to that,
look to those people.
I don't know.
It was this fun level of
legitimacy to use a term that
we've been kind of throwing
around a little bit for the
last hour is--
we're playing in the
same sandbox
basically, and that's great.
For me, it's the best feeling
is knowing that
we're in the same area.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: And now we did
all of this, and we pat
ourselves on the back.
And then we're tasked with--
we got to do it all again.
And we did, and we
had the second
volume, the second semester--
oh, we lost--
MALE SPEAKER: I got it.
JEREMY SALIBA: It's one, two,
three, four, five, right?
MALE SPEAKER: Security's
very tight at Google.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Basically
yeah.
So we did the class again
this past fall.
And then the website--
thank you--
started up again.
The web comic started up again,
which meant the next
step was going to be
going into print.
And so we, again, returned to
Kickstarter and kicked off a
second volume--
or a pitch for a second volume
just about two weeks ago.
And first day we had
a phenomenal--
I'm speechless still--
response that
ultimately saw us get--
we were the number one
staff pick for comics
within about an hour.
I'm not going to pretend to
know exactly how all the
shenanigans at Kickstarter work,
the people that work
there, but they do seem to
genuinely love what we do.
When I submitted the project,
I actually got an email back
from them that seemed
to be personalized.
If it's a bot, it's
a very clever bot.
Young lady saying, welcome back,
and this looks really
cool, and we're excited for
you, blah, blah, blah.
And as I say, after about an
hour, we were number one staff
pick for comics.
We were the number four staff
pick for all projects of any
kind in San Francisco.
And then by after like
six hours, we were
on the front page.
Oh, the front page, and we
were on San Francisco.
So we were on the front
page twice at the
same time, which again--
JEREMY SALIBA: It was
an awesome embrace.
You know, welcome back.
The second volume--
to talk a little bit
about that--
we had, basically, let's get
some new students together.
We did have some returned
students, which was actually
just great because they already
know everything about
what we're trying to do and
what we're working for.
It was a little bit easier in
some respects, again, to do it
a second time because
we had the first
book to give the students.
This is what we did.
This is what it looked like.
Please read it and check it
out and hit the ground
running with us.
So having some new students was
really cool, though, to
get a fresh perspective,
to get some new looks.
Because one of the things
about the book that is a
challenge for me is that we
have all these different
artists, and I'm trying to
create, visually, a through
line through everything.
So for the first one, I
kept it fairly loose.
The first couple weeks, we would
do character designs and
kind of agree, OK, this is what
the character looks like.
He has a scar right there,
two millimeters
down from his hairline.
You know, it was kind of
getting some basic
landmarks in place.
The overall color palette of
each character, getting that
stuff in place.
So those things would be a
through line, regardless of an
individual artist's style.
And the second time through,
one of the things that we'd
heard about Volume
One was that--
some great people, gave us some
feedback and said, you
could get a little tighter,
I think, even with those
different styles.
So that was a big goal for me
was to do that in Volume Two.
We're really excited because
the first volume, it was a
bunch of guys.
It was all gentleman
who joined us.
But in Volume Two, we've had
some ladies come and be
artists, come on the book and
help us, three of them.
I'm a married gentleman, and my
wife is an anti-- she's not
a geek at all.
She doesn't understand
anything--
the appeal to "Star Wars" or
dragons or zombies or any of
that stuff.
And I typically will go to her
with feedback because I want
that ground zero kind
of feedback.
And one thing she always points
out that's lacking in
my work initially is a woman's
perspective, a woman's touch,
and why would I want to leave
out half of the world's
population when I'm trying to
make something that will
appeal, that will speak
out to people.
So having some ladies involved,
to me, is a great
boon because then
we have that.
We have both sides of Earth, of
the human race contributing
to this and giving their
points of view.
The other thing that's
been kind of fun--
Brian and I have been having
conversations about it-- is
that with some students, with
constraints on how many
classes they have and all
that kind of stuff, they
want to do it again.
But they don't know if they
can sign up for the class
again, if they have
room in their
curriculum to do it again.
And Brian and I were recently
having a conversation about --
is it going to be too difficult
to have a student
who's not enrolled in the class
be part of the book?
They're not going to be
part of that format.
We'll have to wrangle them
a little harder.
And Brian was almost bemoaning
the fact that he had so many
people lining up that would want
to work on the book, but
not take the class.
And that's when I pointed out to
him, so you're a writer who
has a bunch of artists who want
to work for you and help
you make a book for free, and
you're upset about that--
and for no initial
upfront cost?
And you're saying that that's
a problem for you?
So I think that's another great
thing, that's another
[? ancillary ?] benefit
of this project.
And what we've done is we're
creating these connections,
these artists, all of which are
talented and some of which
phenomenally talented, and are
going to probably go on to be
superstars.
And of course, they'll
just have to
remember the little people.
But the networking that goes
on, the expansion of your
professional group, it
phenomenally explodes, and
it's a lot of fun.
When we go to signings, and
we do this kind of stuff
together, it's a blast.
We might go out to a local
establishment, have a beverage
or two after the signings.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Public
house, public house.
JEREMY SALIBA: Sure,
thank you.
And hang out with each other.
As much as we're talking about
the hard work element of
everything, it doesn't feel
like it most of the time.
It is a lot of effort,
but I do that anyway.
Look at that drawing,
it should be better.
It should be this and that.
So when I'm doing it
in class, it's just
something I would do anyways.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Speaking for
myself, yes, there's a lot of
work that goes into this.
And frequently, I find myself
spinning a lot of plates
simultaneously, where doing the
website or maybe doing a
Kickstarter.
And then we're doing the class,
and then I'm writing
the next volume.
And occasionally will find
myself a bit stressed out and
then realize, wait, all of these
things, yeah, they might
be time consuming, but I love
them all for their constituent
elements, and I'm
very fortunate.
I see a hand.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Could we leave a little time
at the end for questions?
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Yes.
Actually we are wrapping up.
That's our last little--
thank you, Google.
I'm Brian.
He's Jeremy.
And yeah, fire away with any--
this would be the Q&A
portion of the show.
JEREMY SALIBA: Right.
And really, any question.
Nothing's out of bounds.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: I was wondering, what
would you do differently
if you redid the project?
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Ooh, what would
we do differently if we
redid the project?
You want to field that?
JEREMY SALIBA: There's been a
few aspects of the project.
Volume Two is almost, in
a sense, doing that.
So we've had that chance, in
a way, to kind of-- we're
locking down things and being
a little more stringent on
what the students contribute
to the book.
Being more selective about
who's on the book.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Again, at this
point, we've done it.
We've done the entire pipeline
once, and the entire thing was
a learning experience.
I'd never run a Kickstarter.
I'd never submitted anything
to Amazon.
And meeting industry folks and
basically going up to them
cold and saying,
hey, I'm Brian.
This is my book, blah.
Now that all of that is done,
there were bumps in all those
aspects along the way,
and now we've
corrected for that, I think.
But as far as changing anything
from the outset--
like would we have changed
any aspect of the story?
Would we have done the class
differently from the beginning?
I don't think so.
JEREMY SALIBA: No.
It worked out.
It was great.
It was a of fun.
It worked really well.
That's probably why we
went back for more.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: And I want to
say that I was very blessed
with the fact that Jeremy agreed
to be a part of this
and to actually teach
the class.
I can talk about three point
perspective, and I can talk
about crossing the line, but
I can't-- the minutia of
artistic critiques
is way beyond me.
JEREMY SALIBA: It was a lot of
fun because I get to tell
people how much I hate
their artwork and how
it should be better.
As long as you learn
a few terms--
well, you should select this
out and make sure that the
line of sight's good here--
you sound like you know what
you're talking about.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I was curious
[INAUDIBLE]
who did what and what kind of
feedback did you give people,
get this to change.
JEREMY SALIBA: Thank you.
What kind of process, what kind
of feedback did we do
through the progression
of everything?
This is one of our returning
artists, Mr. John Gomes.
And this is another situation
where we had the good fortune
to know his strengths and
weaknesses, if any.
And so we knew this was going
to be a big splash page.
So initially, he hadn't done
anything like city street
scenes before this.
So I just pulled him aside and
said, hey, you better get the
perspective perfect on this.
It's got to be good.
You know, get reference.
I'm going to ride you like--
BRIAN SCHIRMER: I want to jump
in real quick and say when we
wrote this in the script, I not
only envisioned that it
was going to be in Paris, but
also, when I thought of it, I
pictured the cover of
"Freewheelin' Bob Dylan." And
I basically took an image--
which is another thing that I
actually do in the script is I
will find imagery and reference
online, throw it in
the script.
So I had the album cover there,
and he riffed on that
beautifully.
But please, continue.
JEREMY SALIBA: So let me see.
Well, you can kind of see
some of the progression.
Like, obviously, it's a loose
sketch in the beginning
anyways, so it's
very malleable.
We can talk about things.
And I thought the placement of
some of the cars could use a
little bit of massaging, the
one on the left especially.
And I thought that
the buildings--
there wasn't enough of a
cavernous kind of a feel.
I wanted it to be a little bit
taller, have a little bit more
of a corridor that
they were in.
So those were kind of
my instructions.
I also thought the street
looked-- because this was
supposed to be-- what was
the year that this
scene takes place in?
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Our alternate
1930, I believe.
JEREMY SALIBA: Right.
And the street looked a little
too modern paved in the
initial sketch, so I was like,
maybe even go with, like,
cobblestone or something
like that.
At which point, he made
those corrections.
On this stage, there's some
subtle small things.
He was doing great.
This one is just a
great example.
But the folds in Frankenstein's
sleeves were
just a little unnatural
in the beginning.
We had to kind of
get reference.
It's one of those things where
we'll discuss it and say,
well, if you're not sure,
get reference.
And if you can't find the
reference, let me know because
I'll find you the reference, and
push forward from there.
From that point on, after we
refined the sketch and got to
where we wanted it to
be, it was the inks.
And I didn't have to do much
with him on the inks.
He knows his inking well.
And I liked what he handled with
the silhouettes and how
he hit at a higher-contrast
area right here with black
behind the characters that were
primarily bright to make
that a focal point.
And again, with the readjusting
of these diagonal
lines of perspective to lead
us right to where we wanted
the eye to go, it was just a
matter of letting him have his
fun with it and go crazy.
Then with the color image,
again, he did a great job.
We had the reference.
We kind of established a palette
for everything at this
point already.
I don't know if I ever had a
specific conversation about
the red dress with him,
the color of it.
But it's a great choice.
It complements the green nicely
and, again, reinforces
that focal point.
So that's kind of a typical walk
through of the kind of
things that we would talk
about to make it
as good as we can.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Well, sure.
JEREMY SALIBA: Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: How do you figure out
who worked on which panels
and do you ever have multiple
students working on the same
[INAUDIBLE]?
JEREMY SALIBA: Yes.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: How
did [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
How did we determine who worked
on which pages, and did
we have people collaborating
on any specific pages?
Basically two questions,
we have two answers.
Like I said, this was a
portfolio-driven class.
We had to see what the students
were capable of
before we admitted them
to the class.
So we were able look at that.
And then, usually, in the first
week or two, they are
doing concept designs for,
perhaps, new elements.
And Jeremy and I will,
basically, we will have read
the script.
We will sit down, knowing each
person's strengths, and we'll
say, well, this person might be
best suited for these pages
or this character and so on.
And I don't think we've ever
had anyone complain.
JEREMY SALIBA: Right.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: We do
occasionally get requests
saying, oh, I definitely
want to do Dracula.
And where we can accommodate,
we do.
JEREMY SALIBA: Right, right.
We want them to have fun.
And then in collaboration--
the main collaboration I can
think of in Volume One, two of
our students worked
on the same page.
One of them penciled it, and one
of them inked it, which is
a common way to work in the
comics field anyways.
And they did a great job.
It was the kiss.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: But more often
than not, again, because it's
a class and students need to be
learning all the different
aspects, you've got a student
doing everything.
Like in this case, John did
the original pencils.
He did the final pencils.
He did the inks, and
he did the colors.
JEREMY SALIBA: The other thing
that Brian does, he caters
specifically to the needs of
the students in the class.
In Book Two, he made sure
to have everyone have a
consistent chunk and a run.
So when they have their
portfolio to present to
someone, they've got a nice,
clean run of the story so they
can show it to someone.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Right.
We have learned from contacts
in the industry that when
recruiters are looking at work
that students, or anyone, has
done, who is basically looking
for a job as a sequential
artist, they want to see pages
of sequential storytelling.
They don't want cover design,
cover design, cover design or
just random pages
here and there.
They want to see that
you can tell a good
story straight through.
JEREMY SALIBA: Right.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Sir?
AUDIENCE: So the Kickstarter
portion.
There was a lot of stuff that
seemed time consuming to you
guys-- the Kickstarter
[INAUDIBLE]
Amazon.
So I assume that will get
easier this time.
Maybe not.
But you envision a future
with that, where that
part isn't as necessary?
Or [INAUDIBLE]
self-reinforcing?
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Do we envision
a future where we don't need
Kickstarter?
Would that be a good
way [INAUDIBLE]?
Short answer, at
this stage, no.
Only because, as Jeremy said,
it's more than a passion
project, but it is not
uber lucrative.
Let's put it that way.
The money that does
come through
does pay for the printing.
It does pay for the shipping.
It does pay for some of the
rewards or the perks
and what have you.
But we're not sitting on a big
bag with a dollar sign on it
that then allows us
to go forward.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
time.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: OK.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
JEREMY SALIBA: Yeah,
thanks everyonne.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Thank
you, Google.
Yay.